carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
a
saludos desde parís y bienvenidos a esta
nueva entrega de carrusel de las artes
en este periodo de vacaciones
recordaremos algunos de los temas que
más nos deslumbraron durante la
temporada cultural en francia
la riqueza artística y el exotismo de
los olmecas todavía pueden admirarse en
parís el museo de que bolt y expone
piezas excepcionales de esta
civilización fascinante con más de 3000
años de historia
daremos un paseo por la casa de víctor
hugo y descubriremos facetas
desconocidas del célebre escritor
francés autor de los miserables
conoceremos a la fe électricité una
pintura monumental que rinde tributo a
la electricidad ya los pensadores y
obreros que la hicieron posible
y daremos una vuelta por el sena en
compañía de pilones la nueva diva de la
música pop electrónica en francia
[Música]
comenzamos a este programa llevándolos a
una de las exposiciones más luminosas en
parís 300 piezas de la civilización
olmeca viajaron desde mexico al museo
del que bonnie de la capital francesa y
allí conocimos a la conservadora
mexicana cora falero ruiz quien nos
habló de esta cultura de la que queda
mucho por descubrir
la historiografía en torno a los olmecas
es una historiografía en construcción
son muy pocos años de estudio la primera
vez que se menciona el término el meta
fue en
1927 cuando un académico empezó a
encontrar similitudes en distintos
objetos que habían sido encontrados para
él quedó claro que se trataba de una
cultura no conocida antes pero
completamente identificable
[Aplausos]
es una de las culturas de la que menos
se sabe respecto al resto de las
culturas de mesoamérica es la más
antigua es la que se caracteriza por
estos grandes monolitos o estas grandes
esculturas
la piedra tiene un lenguaje
la materialidad indígena la materialidad
del mezcla también encierra muchos
significados la ofrenda más antigua al
meta fue encontrada en los 90s está aquí
en la exposición data está fechada en el
1600 antes de cristo
[Música]
para nosotros es muy significativo este
interés en este caso francés en términos
generales un interés extranjero en una
cultura que también en méxico es
totalmente reconocida identificable pero
cuya historia está en construcción
todavía entonces es una gran oportunidad
tanto para gméxico mostrar aspectos de
esta cultura como para el museo que
habrán de recibir una exposición de este
tipo
[Música]
y nos quedamos en parís para hablarles
ahora de víctor hugo un monumento de la
literatura francesa y mundial su casa es
hoy un museo donde se descubren facetas
desconocidas del escritor quien fue
también un decorador y dibujante
extraordinario carrusel de las artes los
lleva hasta ese lugar en el centro de
parís
en el número 6 de la plaza de voy a la
plaza más antigua de parís se encuentra
el apartamento que víctor hugo alquilo
entre 1832 y
1848 un lugar decorado a su gusto donde
se evoca no tanto su obra escrita sino
más bien las etapas de su vida las
mujeres que amo sus objetos personales y
sus pasiones secretas el director del
lugar llegar o dinei nos muestra la
intimidad del célebre escritor francés
[Música]
visitó la casa de víctor hugo nos acerca
al hombre este apartamento es como una
biografía a través de los decorados de
cada una de las habitaciones se evoca su
vida antes durante y después del exilio
están sus muebles los retratos de su
familia sus pinturas y algo que se
conoce mucho menos y que sólo se
descubre aquí el víctor hugo decorador
fue algo que le apasionó y que aprendió
en el teatro
y volteado
la casa de víctor hugo en parís se
compone de varias habitaciones repletas
de objetos y un salón chino donde se
revela un aspecto bastante desconocido
del autor de los miserables sus dotes de
decorador víctor hugo de 4 el víctor
hugo decorador fue un artista no cristal
sino cúbico me gustaba adornar no sólo
las paredes sino también el piso y el
techo el mismo escogió la alfombra y
diseñó los marcos de madera de las
pinturas chinas del techo es como si
estuviéramos en un cubo en el que cada
centímetro cuadrado fue pensado por
víctor hugo estamos en su universo
cargado de fantasía poesía y muchas
referencias
para timo para de los dibujos de víctor
hugo no se conocieron durante su vida
para él fue una actividad íntima aunque
hoy figura en el panteón de las artes
gracias a sus dibujos fue su jardín
secreto una manera de comunicar con su
amante juliette e incluso se opuso a que
fueran expuestos el dibujo a la pasión
secreta e íntima
[Música]
y una pintura monumental cuenta la
increíble historia de la electricidad
desde la antigüedad hasta principios del
siglo 20 se llama la fe électricité
helada electricidad y es una boda
pintada por el francés haul wifi que
fuimos a ver al museo de arte moderno de
parís
son 60 metros de largo por 10 de alto
que cuentan en pintura la conquista de
la electricidad la fe électricité es la
obra maestra de raoul dufy para la
exposición universal de 1937 una
composición monumental donde dif y
asocio naturaleza y tecnología y resumió
la historia desde el rayo de zeus hasta
las centrales eléctricas creadas por el
hombre
y
en ese entonces gobernaba el frente
popular que deseaba mostrar una francia
moderna y representó los avances
tecnológicos vinculados a la
electricidad el aeropuerto de burger que
acaba de inaugurarse este lado los
avisos luminosos en las ciudades que
eran una especialidad francesa con la
orquesta sinfónica que se pudo escuchar
a distancia con la primera difusión
radiofónica algo nuevo en los hogares
franceses número 2 jorge difonso
la fe électricité fue durante 50 años la
pintura más grande del mundo y sin
embargo dif y la ejecutó en apenas 10
meses
no cualquiera puede pintar 600 metros
cuadrados en menos de un año pero wifi
fue muy ingenioso por un lado su amigo
el químico ya rajoy e inventó una
pintura muy ligera y fácil de aplicar y
que tenía el aspecto de la acuarela por
otro lado utilizó la técnica de la
linterna mágica primero dibujaba sus
figuras y luego las proyectaba sobre el
soporte además trabajo sobre láminas
minuciosamente cortadas de 2 metros por
50 centímetros para un total de 600
metros cuadrados
esas siete expongo raúl y íntegro en su
composición los retratos de 110 sabios
que contribuyeron al desarrollo de la
electricidad así como a los que trabajan
para hacerla posible
buscan representados desde arquímedes
hasta amperio pasando por fajas de o
edison hay una sola mujer
y también un pequeño personaje azul que
representa a los obreros que hacen
funcionar las plantas eléctricas fue un
mensaje muy importante que difícil
transmitió en su obra
wi-fi terminó exhausto y enfermo con una
pole artritis que se manifestó poco
tiempo después y que lo obligó a poner
fin a su carrera durante la guerra
la fe électricité fue objeto en 2021 de
una limpieza general después de haber
sido fotografiada minuciosamente con
drones esta operación permitió revelar
los colores vivos y transparentes que
empleó wifi
[Música]
y ya que hablábamos de electricidad les
presentamos ahora a una cantante
eléctrica su nombre es prince y ha hecho
un chispazo en la escena musical
francesa natal olivares navegó con ella
por el sena
hasta el no
estamos en el distrito cuatro de parís
cerquita de la plaza de la bastilla en
el esfuerzo nacional y nos vamos de
paseo por el sena con olivia mediátic la
cantante de u2 se lanza en una carrera
solista y nos habla de su nuevo proyecto
fue 2 en el bate
puedo decirte que fue un peligro hacer
un proyecto sola porque de repente me
encontré experimentando sin tener a
nadie que me diera su opinión como lo
era antes y todo el tiempo yo tal
intercambio con dan cuando formamos el
dúo de duch que siempre estábamos juntos
vivíamos juntos hoy trabajo sola y tengo
ya mis costumbres como solista para mí
es un proyecto de emancipación de
liberación y también de afirmación de mi
identidad de forma sólida
hola natalia y háblanos un poco más de
esta chica ruidosa que está poniendo un
pie firme en la french touch hola maria
carolina efectivamente nos está poniendo
un pie firme en la fan este es franco
finlandesa y para llevar a cabo ese
proyecto íntimo utilizo la filosofía
norteña él zizou
zizou
hay un concepto del que me gusta hablar
llamado sí sí es un estado de ánimo
finlandés es propio de los finlandeses
es una especie de fuerza interior que al
origen permiten atravesar los largos
inviernos es algo que te ayuda a
resistir en mucho tome puesto y yo
sentía que sea algún tomaba mucho tiempo
en salir mientras tanto tuve blanco y
después hubo la pandemia había muchas
cosas que retrasaban obstáculos que
teníamos que superar al tiempo que
teníamos que seguir creyendo en el
proyecto seguir adelante con la misma fe
por eso creo en el sismo porque me
aportó bastante en ese mayor gesto sí sí
es verdad mis orígenes finlandeses me
dieron la fuerza y me acompañaron en
todo muchísimas gracias o libia perdón
por habernos recibido en este barco
francés rebatir con fe estamos pasando
por los monumentos
parisinos nosotros de lille san luis una
balada para reconectar a nuestra manera
con la naturaleza muchísimas gracias por
ir a gracias a
mucho
[Música]
gracias néstor olivares por este paseo
por el sena con cuidado si justamente
los dejamos con un tema de esta cantante
o font son muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros en carrusel de las artes y
hasta la próxima favor
[Música]
e
y qué
[Música]